which came first where blood lies the
short film or where blood lies the
feature screenplay so I
wrote the short film screenplay first
and then as I was planning to make the
short film
the feature screenplay was being
developed
and
so yeah
I guess kind of at the same time maybe
and the funny thing with that movie was
like originally I wanted to make a a
short film as a proof of concept
but
the original short film that I wrote
there was like a backstory to you know
one of these characters it was about on
these two kids who find like a hidden
bunker abandoned bunker
and they go in there and you know they
find out there's like this creature but
there was like a whole backstory to like
how this experiment came about
and I scrapped the entire movie but I
like the backstory so I made that into
where blood lies
how much time did you put into shopping
the feature script
I put a lot of effort into it
um you know I
I reached out to you know everybody that
I knew in terms of like Executives or
whoever yeah I mean I did everything I
could
but the feedback that I kept getting was
like
they just didn't know they're like uh
it's gonna be expensive or
vampires like we see a bunch of stuff
with vampires already
you know that was kind of the general
feedback
plus you have the bunker was there like
a cost the thought of this creating this
well
um and it ended up being just a cave so
the bunker thing that was from the
original idea I scrapped that
but I did have a script actually that I
wrote called The Lost bunker
um so like yeah I have a bunch of
scripts
where were you shopping the script and
why didn't anyone want to make it
I don't know
um like I was saying in terms of
shopping the script I just submitted
through my own contacts
um
I mean this was before I got my manager
and you know just through my own
contacts and I don't know why I didn't
want people just don't really they
didn't really see the vision that I was
trying to make
um they saw it as like one of those
I don't know can't be kind of like Nazi
vampire or Nazi Zombie kind of thing
um
which I wasn't trying to really do
and you know the vampire genre people I
think they felt it was outdone already
you know
but yeah
do you remember when you stopped
shopping the script and you said I'm
just gonna make this proof of concept
remember the moment or series of events
I think I always had the idea that I
would
make a short film
for a proof of concept
but
yeah I've always wanted to make the
short film because even if it wasn't
I'm gonna sell the script it was just
something that I can direct and um be a
calling card because if I want to direct
horror films
I have to make something within that
genre and this was going to be it
and you know and I I wanted to just make
something you know I was um getting that
creative bug so
yeah and that's kind of like why I went
and but I wanted to have the short film
and the script ready at the same time so
that you know you have both things to
present to people
Oh you mean the feature screenplay yeah
oh yeah okay interesting so you want to
be ready to go if they say you know can
I see what else do you have well I have
a feature version yeah
how long did it take you to make this
short film
um
planning it took a while because
originally I wanted to make it in Norway
I even went out there and met with a
buddy of mine and a producer and we were
scouting um
abandoned Nazi bunkers
which was kind of fun but
but we ended up saying okay no it's too
expensive over there
but the actual
um production was only three days and
then post-production maybe like a month
or so
and and leading up to it maybe like a
month of prep
because you had stayed two days in
Norway when you went to Germany or this
is different it seems like a different
time this is like
when I was already like about to move
back to America like before I moved back
I was thinking like I could make it in
Norway because at this time I was living
in Germany
so it was like pretty close I just go
over there but everything's so expensive
over there it was like no way
when you release the short film online
how did it do the first day
the first day
I think it got like over a thousand
views
yeah
um
I had posted on Reddit
and
just asking people to comment or
for feedback on it
and um and then you know obviously my
own social media
but yeah
it got all it ended up getting a lot of
views
about a thousand sorry yeah the first
day it was probably a thousand I I can't
really recall but um you know as every
day went on the views started coming in
and you know after I think it was like
well now it's been two years
um
it's got like 2.3 million
and all that is organic views like
besides Reddit and maybe some social
media like I never paid for ads or
anything like that
um
is it was like a surprise to me as well
you know like I was like what the heck
but that goes to show because
um I always knew that that that concept
would do well but nobody believed it but
once I put it out there like the
audience is there you know everybody
was interested in seeing it
do you remember the length of time from
the Thousand to just a million not even
though it's not just a million but
um
I don't know maybe a few months like
it had to be at least a few months
yeah
it's great that's not easy to do with
the success of the short film did you
have producers reaching out to you yeah
I actually
um well it got licensed by gunpowder and
Sky which is a production company
um that does alter
so that's great and the funny thing is
they put it on their Channel and it only
got 60 000 views
so I already like yeah
I'm not sure how the algorithms work but
I think
because I had already posted it maybe
they couldn't get that many views
but besides them another producer slash
writer kind of group
they reached out and they actually
wanted an option the short film
but you know it ended up not working out
because because gunpowder and Sky had
the license ready so we had to wait for
it to expire and then by that time they
had like some other projects that they
were working on which like they got
hired to do some other projects so they
didn't have time to work on their own
thing so they said they'll come back to
me at one point
um which you know you don't know if
that'll happen or not but just having
that interest from them I think was like
a big um you know a boost in morale for
me because
because they told me that hey like their
agents are the ones that were saying hey
go out and like we'll get a short film
and option it and then like develop that
short film as an IP
so there's people out there actively
looking for short films to you know
acquire their rights for
um so that's what got me interested in
like oh well if they got interested in
this maybe I can do the again with
another short film because by creating a
short film you're creating IP
as long as you create a specific world
and characters right
um and then from there
either you make it or somebody else can
make it but you have a piece of Ip now
did you think of possibly a video game
that that's a possibility yeah video
game only recently that I really get
interested in video games with Unreal
Engine
so yeah I mean and you see now with
video game companies they're making
movies now too
um so there's a definitely a big cross
between the two industries
and I think we're going to see a lot
more of that um
in the future years
why isn't the success of the short
enough to get a feature made
I think it really depends on
the
um their circumstance or you know
who is willing or interested in making
something
so
you know we've seen so many instances
where a short film did get make made
into a feature film and
um
and mine almost got made that's the
thing
um which doesn't mean it won't be so
there's there's that card is still in
play
and that's why I I'm somebody who would
say to filmmakers like yeah go and make
a short film because I know some people
say oh don't waste your time on a short
film because
it's not going to make money and nobody
cares about short films that's not true
people will watch a short film over your
feature film because of feature film
they have to spend an hour and a half to
watch it with a short film if it's short
enough they'll watch it because it only
takes like less than 10 minutes and I've
had more people watch my short film than
they've watched my feature films and I'm
talking about like you know like the
showrunner for um Walking Dead watch my
short film and said he loved it
um you know agents at CAA like I mean it
got passed around to a lot of different
people because of the interest from
these producers like
their reps was like taking this film
around kind of like showing it around to
see if there was like interest already
I mean now I know we used to hear that a
lot that you can't make money but now
like there's there's also channels I
know you said gunpowder and Sky put it
on theirs but like amaletto they have
like fantastic sort of films like I
could binge watch that all day and you
know I wasn't necessarily always a short
person but some of the stories that they
have are amazing so yeah I think this
become more prevalent now it seems like
yeah and you can use that short film in
many ways like
um
really as a portfolio piece and a
calling card but if you're trying to be
a a director
like you got to have something to show
that's recent right like I can't show
people something I made 10 years ago and
be like oh yeah hire me to direct
um a horror movie when the film I made
was a drama and it was like 10 years old
and they're not going to watch the movie
anyway because they don't want to spend
an hour and a half watching it but I'm
like oh hire me to direct this script oh
what have you directed oh here's check
out this short film and with a short
film you can really put all your
resources into a very short
um
and just make that
a super high quality right so it won't
cost as much as like making a feature
film but you can still get the same
um achievement like result
which is to prove to someone you can
direct
why do you ever have a tough time
um trying to get a good Arc story arc
for a short or no you you can thrive in
that environment no it's pretty
difficult for me
um and that's why I haven't really made
that many shorts uh like before where
blood lies I made maybe like four shorts
all in film school that nobody should
probably watch but
that was something that was difficult
because with short film structure is
different from a feature film right it's
kind of it has to be sort of like how
you tell a joke
you set it up and there's like a punch
line
um but if you try to approach it as a
feature film it just ends up being like
too much information or too much story
um but I think now
I'm starting to understand it more but
you know
it's probably more difficult actually
for me to come up with a short film